now first off congrats Aquafina
adjoining this Jumanji world did you two
have any advice any guidance from FINA
joining this world cuz it's a weird
world like you're playing multiple
characters like what guidance did you
give her and joining us give her I mean
she didn't really need it like she came
in for the first read-through and we
just read through the whole thing and
she just knocked at the park we were all
just like wow this is the perfect
addition to this whole cast Jack why are
you gonna give me something give me some
kind of scoop I was like when the green
screen comes you got a commit it's gotta
be real to you in here do you assign me
this mug he's wearing a full green
screen suit with the ping pong balls
over there he was and he really got down
it was like I was like don't phone it in
you are really being pursued by mandrels
nor that she knows what's up yeah it was
just a rad to have her on the set she
was like the red new character and it
was fun to have her there yeah
was it timid ating at all to come into
this you know III think it's just
because I watched the first movie so
many times ever loved in and so seeing
them you know in that context it's like
that's their that's you know it's a game
but no I love them we get along well and
they're just great we jump right into
the deep end to write didn't we like to
start with mandrels yeah yeah that
wasn't our first stunt again oh really
the first thing he was a giant stunt
yeah run one rope together yeah it was
double stick hot opening ya know I mean
it's amazing seeing Kevin Hart last
couple days like back in the public
option this is returned to me by the
public as fans we love seeing him back
like what's like for you guys seeing him
honest recovery and how well he's doing
hi so nice to have him back in the day
yeah cuz we were really worried about
him for awhile there
you know it's a major thing that he went
through but just to see how he's come
back with this whole new mental states
he's got like a whole new approach to
life and he's stronger than ever and
it's really great to see him back well
we had the advantage of knowing him and
knowing his circle of friends and people
so we kind of knew before everyone else
that he was gonna be okay it's gonna be
fun and that he was on the mend pretty
early on so but still great to see him
and be around him yeah we couldn't have
done this with it would have felt weird
no way yeah now in terms of a sequel
like there's always so much pressure on
a sequel I feel like there's so much
pressure on the original Jumanji like
people were ready to come for you guys
if that movie wasn't good and it was
great
so was the pressure off a little bit for
the sequel I would say no I mean because
now you have something to live up to I
think when you can you know really
blindside people and go against their
expectations that's amazing but like
with this one the bar is high like
people are expecting good things but
then I read the script and I was like
we're gonna be yeah now finally I feel
like it's criminal that Jack Black
hasn't been in the Marvel movie yet I'm
sure it's going to hell what the hell is
gonna happen but now awkwafina you're
joining the Marvel world so care do you
have it once again do you have any tips
for Aquaman in terms of joining the
Marvel Universe like just the fans are
very you know green screen you gotta
commit to the greens yeah okay like you
really are being precise by Elia there
we can put it on later
yeah we should practice write you down
perfect awesome well congratulations on
the superb you thought thank you thank
you
you